In the last two lessons of our course, we're going to discuss two topics that
many people that are the sum of psychology. That's mental disorders and their
treatments. However, as we talked about in last 14 lessons that this isn't all
psychology has to offer. And as we've said before, many psychologists have
different opinions on different things And mental disorders and their
treatments are two of those things. In fact, many government agencies question
the way we diagnose mental disorders, but we'll get into that in a little bit.
For now, let's go to Susan for an important note on the upcoming lessons. As
we've discussed with many of the topics such as consciousness, arousal, and
stress. We can use the idea of a continuum to look at what is considered
normal, and what is considered not normal. And that's what makes diagnosing
mental disorders so problematic and challenging. In that we have to determine
what is too far on the continuum to be considered normal. Now here when we say
normal, we're talking about this in a statistical sense and not necessarily a
value judgement. Now psychologist who study mental disorders do so to
understand, treat and prevent human misery. When behavior falls outside of the
normal range on that continuum. Many people find this area of psychology very
interesting. And although the way society has treated people with mental
illness has evolved greatly, there are still cross cultural differences in the
way people, view and treat individuals with mental illness.